let's talk about chris Christie because
he's probably running in 2016 actually a
lot of the Democrats like that because
he seems to kind of be one of them but
the only way he'll be able to do it is
if he can get through the Republican
primaries and of course the Republican
primaries are a bunch of right wing
nutjobs who were still anti-gay and that
whole thing now Chrissy himself has
never really come out for gay marriages
actually vetoed things and done things
anti-gay in the state of New Jersey um
and that the problem is that he's gonna
have to keep doing that if he wants to
get out of the Republican Party even
though i think in his heart of hearts he
probably really is in that anti-gay and
he said that if the people voted on it
he would respect their decision of
course you shouldn't leave the rights of
minority up to majority blah blah blah
uh is this uh idea of of gay marriage in
2016 will this have just disappeared by
then cuz it's it seems like now with
DOMA and everything that maybe I haven't
even tweeted about gay stuff in about
two weeks maybe we're actually getting
there and the the primary still gonna
screw it up of course yes see that's the
problem see you're saying we get it it
will matter because I don't see the
Republican platform changing 2016 that's
good the play they will still be
anti-gay so if their anti-gay so then
all of them have to go to the right to
go with that and then you get a damaged
candidate basically what yes what chris
Christie's been saying is you know we
put it up to the vote of the people
which he got course that's exactly the
opposite and he knows that and the real
democracy works actually you you vote on
things but you don't put other people's
rights regul right exactly you vote on a
constitution that ensures people's
rights you don't vote on people's rights
yeah okay i'm with chris christie the
more he's in the pot spot i think it's
great because he's getting revealed to
be the empty as you know as big as he is
he's just an empty shell of a human he's
he's duplicitous he said the critical
he's self-serving he's every horrible
thing you hate about a politician it's
chris Christie so with that said uh is
something like this where the democrats
love this guy cuz you know he goes with
obama and they put their arms around
each other after sandy and all that is
he really though as big of a shell a big
no pun intended like really because he
on something like gay marriage which so
has shifted and the numbers have shifted
anytime the the wave has already begun
this thing's over is he really just
showing what a pandering fool he is
because or just coward he's really being
a coward on this right everyone's saying
that he's worried about the swing votes
and i think that first of all if there's
anyone out there that is a swing voter
yeah you're an idiot at this point at
this point because the parties have told
you what they are if you're like no no
no I think aborted fetuses should go to
jail you know what I mean like you're
just an idiot so he's but he's worried
about the swing vote now so I think
that's why he's swinging he's going left
right he's saying whatever is in the
wind he's he's kind of like that one
that one drunk uncle you have when he's
not drinking you're like oh series there
he is what a sweet kinda and he helped
out by the way get all your dogs after
sandy please get sandy please get your
heart of all bandy dogs but and then he
has a couple of you know off the
Republican wine and he starts to flip
out and you know he's drunk the punch
obviously and he goes back and forth so
much that I think what's gonna happen
this is gonna get very confused and be
made I think you're right be made kind
of made fun of yeah so any problem here
is a problem just that our system does
this so on one side you have to be
completely anti-gay to get through just
to get through the primaries I remember
all those lunatics we had I mean to
think the michelle bachman and Rick
Santorum that they were actually
considered presidential material and I'm
crazy but even on the on the other side
even on the other side you have to be
sort of over that yet mittra exactly but
even on the other side you have to be uh
almost at this point like over the top
for abortion like there's no there's no
middle ground anymore like I don't
really like abortion but if we give
access then maybe women will have
abortions when it's early like no one
really has any sort of we let the doctor
and the woman decide what the best thing
we just stop trying to pretend that we
can get in between and that's the big
again big hypocrites we're all for
privacy the government off our back
except in the most intimate thing
possible they want it so small and fit
in a woman's you
yeah he's gonna get so confused because
he probably has people talking in his
ear who choose to do we're gonna start
priming you for the presidential
election you're gonna go on crossfire
cuz it's good bad and you know and I
think he's just gonna be just he's you
know what I mean he's just gonna get all
tangled up in itself well let's look at
some some numbers about gay marriage and
what's going on here so in 2012
evangelical conservatives who usually
oppose gay marriage obviously made-up
fifty-seven percent of the Republican
caucus goers in Iowa this is an Iowa
caucus-goers I've been to that Club it's
pretty good uh and then in a poll taken
a month after the 2012 caucuses
sixty-four percent of republicans
favored a constitutional amendment
banning same-sex marriage again this is
a year ago and things have changed
because of DOMA so the numbers are
trending definitely four years ago
thirty-seven percent of america's
americans favored same-sex marriage
we're at 51-percent that's going up and
Iowans and that's where the first the
first caucus is favored gay marriage 49
where it's legal to forty two percent
where where it is legal exactly so even
I mean have you been to Iowa it's just
like Sodom and Gomorrah though it's
horrible some believe horrible winter
home societies falling apart yeah it's
horrible marriages people are getting
divorced now because the gays have
ruined and they're threatening a
straight marriage yeah I thought
everybody was ruined honestly I'll tell
you how gay people have threatened
straight marriage this is one hundred
percent true I went to a gay wedding and
these two it was the best
wedding I've ever made my wedding look
like a trip to trader joes yeah all
right and I was like no more gay
weddings that is it what was the MA are
you serious all the appetizers and they
had like a thing a little a flowy bar in
the oyster shells and they did a whole
thing in that entertainment that came in
center and the centerpieces are you
serious they did lights with their
initials in the theme
the dance floor and the band was amazing
so is that what this is really about
that so you guys and them so you
straight people you traditionalists as
we call you are you guys just afraid
we're gonna just take this marriage
thing and make it so freakin great and
it'll expose the fraud of straight
marriage yes are you happy guy yes yeah
yeah so we're gonna sue you I'm gonna
get my Tennessee life and I'm gonna
start suing the gays for being so
fabulous I'm tired of it I've seen two
gays for being gay just imagine happy
yeah sick and tired of it have you I
went to a gay barbecue last week
watching barbecue yeah Tim and see if
you're watching which I hope they are um
over it great food great conversation
amazing yeah I was like forget it you
know what that is true because I just
got a grill and I've been having people
over for barbecues you both are welcome
anytime and I realized between my
boyfriend's an incredible chef I make a
hell of a drink I make mojitos it's all
fresh ingredients you guys drink like
beer what's wrong with you people I
drink a scotch but uh what Scotch that's
a very gay people don't drinks guys
today i don't know i don't think so
Glenlivet quite ready just but oh what
do you make I make a nice rib I make
ribs on the grill really nicely yeah do
you know how to do it yeah we had ribs
this week how'd it go he's good he's
good really it's a rub and then slow and
I go slow and low I don't know how
anybody else does
you